un accord doit être signé dans
l'après-midi en Turquie entre la Russie
et l'Ukraine 20 millions de tonnes de
céréales sont bloqués depuis près de 5
mois en raison d'un embargo de Moscou un
accord attendu dans un contexte
d'inflation et de hausse des prises
agricoles des corridors maritimes
sécurisés doivent être en place on
retrouve shona batacharia notre
correspondante à Istanbul tout d'abord
que prévoit cet accord
alors pour l'instant nous avons vraiment
très très peu d'informations sur ce que
ce que contient cet apport tout ce qu'on
sait pour l'instant ce qui prévoit il
prévoit il prévoit la reprise des
exportations des céréales bloquées dans
les ports au sud de l'Ukraine et pour
sur la mer Noire et qu'il faciliterait
en retour l'exportation des céréales et
des engrais russes alors déjà la semaine
dernière les délégations militaires
russes ukrainiennes turques et des
représentants des Nations Unies avaient
été mis d'accord sur la création d'un
centre de coordination ici à Istanbul
ainsi que des contrôles conjoints au
port de sortie et d'arrivée et la
sécurité des transferts sur les
itinéraires de
la sécurité des navires sur les
itinéraires de transfert alors à l'heure
où je vous parle les négociations
continuent avant la signature qui doit
avoir lieu plus tard cet après-midi la
délégation ukrainienne pour sa part
prévient qu'elle nous soutiendra
seulement les décisions qui garantit la
sécurité des régions au sud de l'Ukraine
ainsi que une forte présence des forces
militaires
ukrainiennes en mer Noire et alors la
délégation russe elle affirme que
l'Union européenne aurait proposé de
baisser les sanctions contre Moscou pour
permettre la mise en place de cet accord
cela donne à la Turquie une place
particulière
oui bien sûr ça fait depuis le début du
conflit que la Turquie se pose en
médiateur et ça fait deux mois que la
Turquie travaille pour conclure un
accord sur notamment ses céréales
ukrainiennes bloquées le président
récepta est perdant d'ailleurs devrait
être présent ce vendredi à la signature
de cet accord ainsi que le secrétaire
général de l'Union des Nations Unies
Antonio guteres mais malgré ça nous
avons toujours très peu d'informations
comme je vous disais un instant
notamment sur comment ces navires seront
sécurisés et s'il y aura un déminage au
moins partiel des ports Ukrainiens en
mer Noire merci beaucoup shona
batacharia merci à vous